days after Khloe Kardashian praised her
ex Tristan Thompson on his birthday a
source tells E.T where the two stand
today own whatever it is on Monday the
reality star called the basketball Pro
the best father brother and Uncle
alongside pics of their daughter true
and their eight-month-old son but don't
mistake Coco's kindness as anything else
our source says she's in a good place
and has set boundaries with Tristan he
will always be in her life but she isn't
in love with him quote she chooses to be
supportive both publicly and privately
for the sake of their children I think
working on your personal growth
internally is something that will be a
forever
um Mission Chloe and Tristan have been
through many highs and lows together if
we rewind back to 2021 the two called it
quits after his cheating scandal where
he bothered a child with another woman
everything is an act of betrayal
everything is a lie everything is
manipulation it's deceit that all went
down as the pair was expecting a baby
boy via surrogate the little one whose
name has yet to be revealed was born
last August ever since December it's
been this Dark Cloud looming over me
every single day I've been feeling
depressed and sad and now that my son is
here I get to move on and I get to enjoy
it's almost like I get to close that
chapter and be done with this trauma and
put it behind me
after all that drama our source says
Chloe can now finally talk about what
Tristan's put her through without
getting emotional it's such a beautiful
thing
quote Chloe has the biggest heart and
sometimes that is her downfall she is
forgiving loves with everything she has
and is so loyal but she is focused on
co-parenting and taking care of herself
right now I'm gonna figure it all out I
promise you Chloe's also been there for
Tristan in the wake of tragedy his mom
Andrea died suddenly in January it's
Andrea's first granddaughter
Tristan's mom
is here with us today Andrea
I am so happy and excited for my
daughter oh I don't have a daughter
but
um when I'm when I'm texting Chloe I
always put to my daughter
et's learned the mom of two's been
spending time with the NBA star ever
since and acting as an amazing support
system making sure he doesn't feel alone
I think also motherhood just puts life
into perspective and what's important to
you but Coco's making it very clear
she's a single gal the Kardashian star
who's known for posting quote pics about
love and life shared this cryptic one
recently being single and posting love
quotes to confuse people is another
level of fun and I love it
[Music]